[Music]
the biggest mistake I think people make
in their communication is we start from
the wrong place you communicate hundreds
of times every day
but are you doing it well we start by
saying here's what I want to say versus
what does the audience or person I'm
speaking to need to hear and that's a
fundamental mindshift
[Music]
welcome to grit and growth from Stanford
seed the podcasts where Africa and South
Asia's Intrepid entrepreneurs share
their trials and trials with insights
from Stanford faculty and Global experts
on how to tackle challenges and grow
your business
[Music]
here's a classic scenario you're on an
elevator
the doors open and in walk someone who
could change your life
till you reach the ground floor to
communicate your message no notes no
slide decks just you could you do it I'm
not sure I could even if someone pulled
the fire alarm and gave me an extra 20
minutes
on a previous episode we dove into how
to prepare for Planned presentations but
the truth is the majority of our
communication in business and life is
unplanned and for entrepreneurs the
stakes can be really high you have to be
ready to speak when you least expect it
because whether you're ready or not you
will be called on by Bosses ask tough
questions in job interviews and
introduce to potential investors at a
moment's notice the ability to
communicate your message in those
situations can be a game changer both
personally and professionally but for
many of us public speaking is stressful
enough even with the safety rails on so
how do you overcome anxiety gain
confidence and rehearse for an
unscripted performance
well if you have his number you call up
Matt Abrahams and you ask him if he'll
help absolutely Darius it's great to be
back with you I'm Matt Abrahams I teach
strategic communication at the business
school I host a podcast called think
fast talk smart luckily even if you
don't have Matt's number you can still
get his advice he's releasing a new book
this month called think faster talk
smarter it's all about how to succeed in
those unscripted moments and it starts
with addressing a challenge that many of
us face even before we open our mouths
so anxiety looms large in all
communication the new book is really
about spontaneous communication how to
communicate in the moment like answering
questions giving feedback you make a
mistake you have to fix it small talk
and a lot of us get nervous in all
communication but especially spontaneous
and there's a categorization of these
different symptoms and results that's
easy to remember ABC there's the
affective the emotional component
there's the behavioral what happens to
your body and then the cognitive part
what happens in your mind so that's the
a b c and most of us myself included who
get nervous experience all of the ABCs
okay so I'm going to tell you my abc
story yes so I was relatively new
employee at a large International
non-profit I was in the senior
leadership team and they had arranged a
meeting with the leadership of the Ford
Foundation oh wow you know crucial donor
organization sure the president of the
Ford Foundation was there and they said
Darcy should come along and you're going
to present on your piece of work well I
was relatively new I had hyper extended
my knee playing sports so I was on
crutches and painkillers I took the
train down there and I was just sweating
from these painkillers and on crutches
in downtown Manhattan we go into this
room and it's a big board room and very
formal and my boss the president of this
organization is very eloquent just kills
it says amazing interesting things and
then turns it over to me and within a
millisecond I just felt hot
like I couldn't even pick up my glass of
water my hand was shaking so intensively
and my vision became tunnel like I
actually started I thought oh my God I'm
having a heart attack am I going to pass
out here you know and this Vision got
kind of dark around the edges and I
could not produce a coherent sense I
mean it was terrible I'm really sorry to
hear that but I want you to remember and
everybody listening in is you survived
you've had an amazing career since then
and a lot of us need to put our anxiety
into that perspective where it's bad
it's not great but you'll get through it
you experienced many of the things that
happened to us your body experiences
these situations as a threat and you go
through fight or flight it didn't help
that you had crutches and you were on
some kind of painkiller that adds a
little extra to it but many of us do
that I perspire and blush when I get
nervous and I used one of the techniques
I talk about in the book if you hold
something cold in the palms of your hand
and it actually cools you down your your
palms are thermoregulators for your body
just like your forehead or the back of
your neck so there the nice thing is
there are techniques we can use to
manage the ABCs and I like to say to
take them from capital letters to lower
case letters so it doesn't go away but
you're at least still managing I want to
talk about the things you do before
you're going to have to speak sure and
the things you can do in the moment when
you feel the wave coming you know the
wave of panic yeah what do you do like
in the moment I just literally wanted to
say I'm sorry I'm having a heart attack
right now and I'm gonna go and leave
somebody called 9-1-1 yeah so grabbing a
glass of cold water but I was like what
are the mental things I can do what do I
tell myself and you say that we're
fixated on our own awareness of others
watching us yes negative thoughts and
self-talk what is self-talk so we all
carry around this voice in our head and
the voices is often helping us be
successful but at times especially under
stress and threat we'll say really bad
things to ourselves we'll say things
like you should have been better
prepared how'd you get yourself in the
circumstance why are you doing this and
not the other person and we can actually
transform that into something more
positive athletes do this all the time
Mantra positive affirmation whatever you
want to call it but by setting up a
positive Cascade in your mind it can
help you so for example a golfer as he
or she approaches a putt might say calm
or focus and that Tunes out all of that
other chatter so when I speak I do this
I use a positive affirmation whenever I
speak in fact before we started today as
I was walking down to the studio we're
recording in I said this to myself my
positive affirmation is I have value to
bring I remind myself that there are
things I know that others might benefit
from often when we're asked to speak
planned or spontaneous people want to
hear from you because you've got
something to say and if you remind
yourself of that that could cancel out
all that little nagging self-doubt so
there are things things you can do
mentally to help yourself so you
mentioned in the book everyone can have
their own unique anxiety management plan
their amp so a mantra is that part of
your amp yeah so my anxiety management
plan after Decades of honing this are
three things one I will always hold
something cold in my hand the studio
we're recording in is actually quite
cold so I don't need that I'm hopefully
not blushing as we speak I will say that
positive affirmation I have value to
bring and then I this is silly but I say
tongue twisters and I say tongue
twisters for a very specific two
specific reasons
I find that my mind often races when I'm
in circumstances where I need to speak
and I need to get more present-oriented
slow down I stop worrying about
potential negative future outcomes
saying a tongue twister gets me very
present focused huh so saying a tongue
twister holding something cold and
reminding myself I have value to bring
is what I do but to truly address
anxiety Matt says you have to change
your mindset and I mean really change it
on my first day of my MBA classes I tell
my students that I want them to strive
for mediocrity and you can imagine
Stanford mbas have never been told to
strive for mediocrity it's always you
know achieve greatness the rationale
behind that is when you actually put a
lot of pressure on yourselves to do it
right we actually just have less
bandwidth it's a complete cognitive
bandwidth issue your brain is like a
computer it's not a great analogy but it
works for this if you have lots of apps
running and windows open your CPU is
running less well each app is run less
well and the same is true if I'm
constantly evaluating and judging
everything I'm saying it means I have
less cognitive bandwidth to focus on
what I'm saying I've been doing this a
long long time there is no right way to
communicate there are better ways in
worse ways but there is no one right way
and we put that pressure on ourselves to
do it right we actually reduce the
likelihood that we'll do it well at all
so I tell this to my MBA students and by
the end of the class that very first
class I say the rest of the saying is
strive for mediocrity so you can achieve
greatness if you turn down that volume
of the judging and the evaluating and
the wanting to do it perfectly you
actually free up resources to do it
really well so this is part of the
previous point about self-talk and like
doing this perfectly is this as well as
I could possibly do it which is all just
brain space being wasted it is it is and
you're not focusing on your audience
that's right you're disconnected so um I
had the fortune for the book to
interview the journalist Joan London and
she was sharing her experiences with
anxiety and how this was a big issue for
her doing it right and she said after
reading your book Matt I came up with
the perfect phrase to help me with this
issue and she said it's about connection
not Perfection I love that your goal in
communication is to connect and to
respond and if I'm in my head trying to
do it right I am absolutely not
connecting and it's going to be harder
to respond but why stop at mediocre Matt
says you can be boring too you wrote In
the book that improvisational performers
tell themselves to dare to be dull yes
don't strive to be a cathedral focus on
being as useful a brick as you can be
it's really this notion that we feel
pressure in meetings in pitches to just
be magnificent to be the best version of
ourselves in that moment and the reality
is it's hard to do that all the time and
so it's important to realize that
sometimes the most important things that
get done are just laying a brick you
know a beautiful cathedral is nothing
more than a lot of bricks and so you
need to think about when I'm in the
pitch meeting maybe the best thing I can
do is be quiet and listen or just say
tell me more when you redefine your role
in this way more skills become part of
your toolkit
often the best way to communicate
requires no talking at all a lot of the
info information in this book and in my
teaching around spontaneous speaking
comes from many places but improvisation
is one of them and improv has these
amazing maxims that just stick in your
head and don't just do something stand
there is really about being present and
do what's needed in the moment many of
us come into these circumstances
pre-programmed with things we we want to
do so if we actually slow down
see what's needed in the moment we can
then respond better imagine you and I
Darius we come out of a meeting and you
say to me hey Matt how'd that meeting go
and I immediately click into oh I gotta
give feedback well you didn't do this
well or you did this kind of well I
think we failed here and yet had I just
waited a moment and listened really and
by listening not just to what you said
but how you said it I might have noticed
you came out of the room through the
back door that you spoke a little more
quiet than usual you were looking down
rather than looking at me when you asked
for feedback and maybe what you really
need in that moment is support you don't
feel the meeting went well and you're
asking for feedback but what you're
really asking for is support
so if you're taking the focus off
yourself where does it go you say think
about your audience not yourself yeah
help me understand how does that improve
my own ability to speak spontaneously
with power and persuasiveness sure the
biggest mistake I think people make in
their communication the fundamental
mistake people make is we start from the
wrong place we start by saying here's
what I want to say versus what does the
audience or person I'm speaking to need
to hear and that's a fundamental mind
shift we all suffer from the curse of
knowledge we know way too much about
what we communicate about and if I don't
understand from your perspective what's
important for you what knowledge you
have now versus where I would like you
to be I can't tailor my message so we
really need to be other focused now the
nice thing about being other focused is
not only does the message is the message
more likely to land the other person is
likely to feel more valued because
you're tailoring the message to them and
again it gets you out of your own head
you're in service of your audience so
that Spotlight that many of us carry
around feeling that's focused all on us
we're being judged and evaluated is now
partially turned if not completely
turned on the audience and that releases
some of the pressure that we feel so I
think it's fundamental and if there were
only one thing that people took away
from my book and if that were it I would
actually be happy when you work in
service of your audience you begin to
see them as collaborators not combatants
so let's talk about the audience yeah
yeah sure you're standing there up on
stage there's 200 people out there
and I tend to wonder do they want me to
succeed or do they are they secretly
hoping you know that I'll trip over my
foot and fall flat on my face what I
mean there's a great you had this great
quote from the Google executive Kathy
Bonanno and she says most audience
members Harbor a simple desire in posing
questions to speakers
to have a good moment with the speaker a
heightened sense of connection and
immediacy yeah and I was thinking about
that because when I get a question from
the audience I'm often my immediate
reaction is defensiveness like what are
they it's a gotcha they're trying to
throw out a gotcha question yeah so my
simple question back to you is when
you're in the audience do you sit there
wanting the person to fail probably not
most of us don't there are a few people
who like to watch people suffer but that
that's not the norm we get defensive
when we feel under threat and that makes
sense and that's why a big part of this
mind your mindset chapter is really
about reframing these circumstances as
opportunities if you think about it
if I see our communication as a threat
I'm going to get defensive it's going to
affect my body posture I'm going to be
uptight I'm going to make myself small
my answers or responses are going to be
very short my tone is going to be Curt
and off-putting yet if I were to reframe
it as an opportunity when you ask me a
question it's an opportunity for me to
connect to learn where your head is at
to expand and collaborate and that
changes my whole demeanor I open up my
posture my tone is more collaborative
and open my answers are longer now the
other thing I do if I know I'm going to
speak to a large audience but we're
doing stuff beforehand like maybe
there's a formal dinner and then I have
to speak I try to talk to as many people
as possible because it humanizes the
crowd right because when you're up on
stage you can barely first of all I
can't focus on anybody I'm too stressed
right so but if I na I have now spoken
to eight or nine of the people who are
out there they're kind of my peeps now
you know I'm like well I know that
person and I know that person we we sure
to laugh that's great yeah I would only
amend what you said by saying instead of
talk to the other people listen to the
other people listen give them just
enough and you'll realize the one thing
you'll realize is these people are here
to learn something to have a good
positive experience they're not here to
judge and evaluate and when you reframe
your relationship with the audience you
start to see all the ways that they can
help you I like arriving early to events
so if I'm coming to a meeting and I know
I'm later on the agenda I like just to
see what people are talking about what's
going on that can help me I've been
known to start meetings and even
presentations or spontaneous Small Talk
where I just put a topic out there to
get other people discussing it and I'm
learning a lot by what they're saying
what they're not saying to help me Focus
it's a continual process where I am
uncovering it's like peeling back an
onion really uncovering the specifics of
of what people know and don't know the
goal is to engage in a conversation many
people just want to get through their
material instead of thinking about how
do I actually adjust and adapt it as
needed in the moment and for me as
somebody who talks a lot you know I go
around doing all this for me that's
really more exciting because I can get
through my material pretty easily it's
really having the conversation and
seeing how it affects others and where
does it take us that's exciting so
that's a sort of reframing the going
back to your anxiety management plan you
know the Mantra is I have something of
value to offer right but maybe the part
two of that is my audience has something
of value to give that's right absolutely
I could learn from my audience if I give
them the space
[Music]
focusing on the audience can also help
you focus your content you describe
relevance yeah why should the audience
care and so we have known for a long
time in sociology and psychology that
relevance salience are really important
if you can make something relevant to
people it's been shown that they process
it so much more thoroughly and invest a
lot of effort if it's not important we
peripherally process it so really
thinking about what's important to the
person this is where emotion can come in
if I can get you emotionally engaged if
I can show what I'm saying is consistent
with things you've done in the past that
makes it more relevant for you so
relevance is really key a lot of us when
we pitch goods and services or our
companies we assume that people will see
the relevance and that's true in our
communication we assume that if I set up
everything that you'll connect all the
dots and that's not always true so we
really have to point out the relevance
for people I think that makes me want to
jump to chapter six great the f word of
spontaneous speaking which is not what
most of my audience will think I mean
what is the F word of spontaneous
speaking it is focus
so many of us when we speak in the
moment are discovering what we want to
say as we're saying it and we tend to
take people on a journey of our
Discovery because you in your own mind
you're putting the narrative together my
mother has this quote it's it's my
favorite quote and she didn't create it
I haven't been able to figure out who
did it's tell me the time don't build me
the clock and many of us are clock
Builders because either because that's
the way we think or it's because we feel
everybody has to understand how we got
to where we got right and that's not
true sometimes people just want to know
the time
turning your focus outward goes beyond
pitches and presentations it can help
you with one of the most fraught types
of communication another application is
giving feedback yeah and I think a lot
of our listeners are you know they run
companies they're they're Business
Leaders their Executives and they're
constantly in a position of either
wanting to give feedback and not knowing
how or giving feedback and maybe
regretting how they gave it or they
think they gave great feedback but it
didn't land yes it's one of the hardest
things I think we do as Leaders so give
me give me some tips tricks tools
applications shortcuts whatever you want
to call it part of feedback is it has to
be part of your culture and your
relationship with the person that you're
speaking to if all you do is give
critical feedback or constructive
feedback
and you only do it when something bad
happens then or only once a year or only
yeah even worse only once a year then
you're setting yourself up to make this
a much harder task when you give
feedback be very clear on what it is
you're looking for many of us are just
so frustrated upset at whatever's
happening or not happening that we're
not very clear for ourselves or for the
person that we're asking for the
feedback from what it is we want so you
have to Define it so now what yeah what
is the now what and is it measurable
well you both know when you see it I
have a very dear friend who has given
feedback to be less assertive what does
that mean what does that look like but
if you say I need you to speak last in a
meeting we can measure that we
understand that so you have to figure
out what it is you want how can you
measure it and then the last thing I'll
say before giving feedback is that you
should think about what might lead the
person to do the thing that you're
seeing or not do the thing that you're
seeing when my two boys were much
younger I was in my office and I hear
this loud crash I come running out there
my older son is standing up on the
counter having reached over his head for
a plate that had clearly slipped and
fall and shattered so being a good
parent I notice there's no blood what do
I do immediately after that I start
yelling what are you doing up there
that's dangerous you shouldn't be doing
it through his tears he says he was
trying to get the plate down for his
younger brother because they knew I was
in the office doing important work and
they didn't want to interrupt me how did
I feel like a total jerk right did he
need feedback did he need constructive
feedback absolutely
I would have given it very differently
had I understood the circumstances that
led to the behavior so we those are the
things that we have to do before we give
the feedback
[Music]
these tools won't just improve your
professional communication they'll help
you in your everyday life with
colleagues with friends even with family
members you know that's support not
feedback thing it's something when I
read that part of your book it really
got me thinking about how I interact
with my teenagers yeah you know and my
wife yeah you know they'll come to me
sometimes how is your day and they'll
give me an honest answer like oh man you
know I have this conflict with my
colleague and I immediately go into
problem solving mode and my daughter has
said dad you are so task oriented it's
impossible to have a conversation with
you because she didn't want me to give
her an action item and a to-do list and
Report out tomorrow now when you know
she wanted me to say you're gonna be
okay yeah yeah or or yeah that really
does suck or that really does suck yeah
yeah no I get the same thing especially
for my wife and my close friends I think
there's something about how some of us
are wired to be problem solvers and and
I've learned to ask so I will now ask my
wife and my close friends I'll say I'm
here to support you and I'm fine doing
that but I can also help you problem
solve and sometimes they'll say yeah I
want problem solving and sometimes I'll
say thanks for just listening it's hard
for me and then you know I might send
them an email with all the to-do lists
afterwards but in the moment I'm trying
to I mean my kids are I I wake up every
Sunday and make a to-do list and I'm not
allowed to have fun till I get through
it my kids think I'm a total freak you
and I are very similar I'm like I'm kid
I'm just hoping this rubs off on you a
little bit someday you know
[Music]
of course some audiences will be more
skeptical than others the oppositional
audience member audience is not really
the right word because it's spontaneous
speaking it could be just one other
person it could be yeah and maybe
somebody you're hoping will co-invest
with you or fund your Enterprise or
partner with you to expand to a new
country and they're challenging you yeah
right and you're trying to bring them on
your journey what are the tricks and
tips for bringing in a sort of an
oppositional conversation back to where
you want it to be first you have to
listen you have to slow down there's
this framework I use that I borrowed
from one of our colleagues his name's
Collins Dobbs it's Pace space Grace you
have to slow down we move so fast and
when I feel like somebody's opposed I
get into this fight-or-flight frenzy and
by slowing down that can help
give yourself some mental space to
actually think about why might the
person be pushing in this way what my
person's concerns be and then give
yourself some Grace to really listen to
your intuition but also to what you're
thinking in those moments if somebody's
highly oppositional or challenging to me
first I want to validate that I'm
understanding it so I like to use
paraphrasing I'm not agreeing by
paraphrasing I'm not agreeing I'm just
am I hearing you right so what I hear
you say is or I might say cost is
something that's really important and I
hear you saying that right and just that
validation one makes the other person
feel listened to which always feels good
and then number two if I'm off the
person can correct me so I want to be I
want to make sure we're focused on the
right issue so paraphrasing sometimes I
will ask more follow-up questions to
again try to make sure I'm understanding
from there I immediately try to
understand if I can in the moment what
might be motivating this circumstance
there's a story I tell in the book it's
from my colleague Adam Tobin and he is a
screenwriter by profession in he went in
to pitch a show and somebody was
pitching to said help me understand why
this isn't science fiction and Adam's
thinking this isn't science fiction
there's nothing science fiction about it
and he he said tell me more why are you
asking about science fiction and the guy
said well my boss who you're about to go
pitch to has been burned by two or three
previous science fiction Endeavors so in
that moment that opposition was actually
a gift because Adam learned something
there that he wouldn't have known
otherwise when somebody is opposing your
point of view if you just take time to
understand what might be motivating it
there might be something there that's
really important right so it's not now
you have a solution to their other
problems that's right or it wasn't
really a problem it was some other issue
but you have to slow down you have to
think about those things and I like to
say challenging questions and issues are
really gifts they're gifts that can
really help you if you put yourself in
that mindset to speak spontaneously in
these difficult situations you have to
do something that might seem
counter-intuitive prepare
so I've done I've had a lot of board
meetings in my life and one of the
things I've learned about board meetings
is to try to think of every possible
challenging question you might be asked
yeah absolutely and to actually sit down
with your team and say okay we think
this all makes total sense but what if
we're asked you know X Y and Z it
doesn't mean scripting your answer it
just means being ready yeah that that's
there are lots of ironic statements in
this book like strive for mediocrity but
the other is prepare to be spontaneous
what you just described is preparation
it makes sense I love the role of a
devil's advocate in meetings and groups
and what you're describing is okay we
know our stuff let's pretend we don't
what are the things that we'll get I
think generative AI is a great tool for
generating questions if you're an
interview candidate type in questions
for this company for this role it'll
spit things out for you know if I'm
pitching to somebody type in what what
are the three key issues and then
practice not memorize not over rehearse
but practice answering those questions
it makes a lot of sense and here's one
of the secrets of spontaneous
communication you can structure it all
communication getting spontaneous or
planned needs to be gold driven we don't
just ramble high stakes I mean we have
conversations that ramble but you want
to go into it saying what do I want
people to know how do I want them to
feel and what do I want them to do that
is the general orientation or Direction
you're going how you get there is the
structure
so if you look at the book The
methodology the six steps it really
breaks into two one is mindset we've
spent a lot of time talking about that's
everything from managing anxiety to how
you approach it to listening and then
the second part is messaging and that's
what you're asking about Now messaging
is about structure our brains are wired
for structured information we do very
poorly with lists and bullet points
bullets kill don't kill your audience
with bullet points rather we should
structure and by structure I mean a
logical connection of ideas beginning a
middle and an end so when I go into
pitch people think well I've got a deck
of course it's structured there's a
difference between an ordering of slides
and a logical connection of that
information
so I believe a fundamental tool to
speaking period but also critical in
spontaneous speaking is how you
structure that information and there are
many structures in the second half of
the book itemizes
it's storytelling it is storytelling and
all good stories have a structure the
structures are not rigid they're
flexible but it's it's like a road map
it's going to get me from A to B but I
can go you know a longer way or a more
direct way but the structure helps me
get from one place to the next and so
this is about finding the right
structure for the right situation so if
I'm asked on the spot to introduce a
colleague there's a structure I could
use that helps because in that moment I
have to solve two fundamental problems
what do I say and how do I say it a
structure tells you how to say it so a
very common structure one that many of
your listeners are probably familiar
with is problem solution benefit there's
an issue or challenge or threat
we have a solution a service a product
an offering that addresses it and here
are the benefits of doing it now you
have lots of flexibility in that
structure maybe it's not really a
problem maybe it's an opportunity
nothing's wrong but things could be
better so problem solution benefit for
anybody pitching I think is great so
there's another structure that I really
like for really tight elevator pitch
executive summary pitching it's a four
sentence starters so the first is what
if you could
so that is the second for example is the
third and that's not all if you finish
each of those sentences I think you have
a very tight clear concise structure for
an idea a product a service what if we
could check market prices for sorghum in
rural Africa using just a feature phone
that's right so that so that farmers
would not get ripped off by middlemen
right for example this is where if you
have an example of somebody using it or
or an analogous Solution that's what so
for example
for example this puts an extra 20
percent into the pockets of actual
primary farmers and that's not all and
this is where you would add some
additional feature by having this data
that we collect we can then do some for
example so what would you say so that's
not all
so that's not all now that they're on
the platform they can also band together
and negotiate prices for group purchases
excellent and for everybody listening
that was completely spontaneous and yet
I think it's a pretty coherent pitch
foreign
structure doesn't just help the speaker
tell the story it helps the audience to
remember it and that's important because
often your audience will be your
Ambassador you say in the book one of
the greatest benefits of adopting a
narrative structure is repeatability
yeah often the venture capitalist with
whom an entrepreneur might be meeting
isn't the one making the final decision
about whether to provide funding that
person has to go back to their firm and
Pitch the entrepreneur's company to
others can you say a bit more about
repeatability yeah absolutely so and
it's not just for entrepreneurs pitching
it's for an interview candidate very
rarely does the person who's
interviewing you in that moment say
you're hired they have to go sell you on
your behalf so much of our communication
is about equipping others with our
message to go do work on our behalf and
so part of your job is not just getting
your message across it's about providing
a structure and a package of that
information so somebody can go easily do
it
thank you
spontaneous communication is hard it can
be unexpected in high stakes no two
situations are ever the same
but it's also all around us which means
you've got endless opportunities to
practice what are some ways you can
practice things like
structuring your spontaneity or the f
word of spontaneity there is a structure
that I really like I'll give you one
example it's three questions what so
what now what the what is the idea your
product your process the so what is why
is it important it's the relevance and
then the now what is what comes next and
you can do a lot with this you can write
emails this way this now what is the
subject line the what and the so what
are in the body of the email you can
give feedback the what is my feedback
the so what is why is it important and
now what is what I'd like you to do
differently how do you get good at that
you practice so I would challenge
everybody at this very moment after I
explain the task pause this podcast
think to yourself what is something I
learned why is it important to me and
how can I use it and then turn the
podcast back on because we want people
to finish this thing but but the point
is listen to something read something
have a conversation then think to
yourself what was it about why was it
important how can I use it that drilling
is just like an athlete will do drills
to prepare them so that's one way in
terms of focus
the thing I like to do is I will read
something or listen to a podcast episode
I'll do the whatso what now what for it
and then I'll say Okay cut that in half
how could I cut what I just said to
myself or wrote in half because what
it's training me to do is to prioritize
I'm picking something that's more
important than something else wait so
this is an exercise you do when you're
editing your own podcast absolutely it's
an exercise I do when I'm having a
conversation this is something I should
do but no I do this so I will go back
and look at text messages I sent I tend
to be a pretty verbose texter which is
ironic I know but I'll go back and I'll
say how could I have said that text in
half the words interesting or I'll my
wife helps me do this all the time
because again I'm still a work in
progress after talking to one of my kids
she'll say minimal words how could you
have said that you you talk too much
they tuned out and so I'll think about
it so I'm training my brain to
prioritize what's the most important so
that when I am put under the spot I will
have that skill available so I can be
more parsimonious that practical element
is one of my favorite things about think
faster talk smarter one thing I want to
say about your book which I asked
absolutely love thank you is it for
every piece of guidance you give you
also give exercises you say go home and
try this next time you're alone do this
or when next time you're having a
conversation with your family try this
and then you also have little tables
with kind of like cheat sheets and I'm
I'm not joking when I say that I'm going
to have some of these printed out
smaller that I carry around in my pocket
when I have to speak because they are
that solid it's just well thank you I
think communication is something you
have to do it's not something you think
about just theoretically and my
publisher for the book said how will you
know if your book was successful and you
know they're thinking do you want to be
on this list or that and no I will be
successful if people do exactly what you
said if there are dog-eared Pages
highlighted and people are returning to
it that's success because communication
is about doing
as humans we are communicating
constantly you'd think we'd be better at
it but it's not easy so don't be so hard
on yourself if speaking makes you
nervous develop an anxiety management
plan prioritize connection not
Perfection there's no right way to
communicate
reframe your relationship with your
audience think of them as collaborators
not adversaries and consider what's
relevant and important to them that will
help you focus your content
structure your spontaneity don't try to
build the tracks while you drive the
train you can lean on established
structures like problem solution benefit
it'll make your content easier for the
audience to remember and more
importantly easier for them to repeat as
with anything practice makes perfect
check out some of the exercises and
think faster talk smarter print them out
fold them up and put them in your pocket
practice when the stakes are low on an
email to A co-worker or in a
conversation with friends if you do that
with your everyday communication you'll
be ready when you get ambushed by a big
moment
[Music]
because as Matt says communication is a
skill one that you can improve a lot of
people feel that based on their
temperament based on their experience
that getting better at spontaneous
speaking or any speaking or any
communication isn't for them there are
some people who are have The Gift of Gab
there's some people who just don't seem
to be as nervous and they can do it and
the reality is everybody can get better
at it for some people they're a little
farther along in the journey but they
too need to hone their skills so I
absolutely think people can develop this
and that's an important thing to feel
that you have a sense of agency that
when somebody calls on you and says what
do you think or when you're asked to
give a toast in the moment or you make a
mistake and you have to fix it you can
actually get better at doing those
things it takes time and it takes work
but you can't there is hope yeah more
than hope it's exciting because when you
do that all of a sudden good things
happen for you I'd like to thank Matt
Abrahams for coming on the show I was
fortunate to get a proof of think faster
talk smarter in mine already he has
dog-eared Pages margin notes and
Post-its all over it you can find it
wherever good books are sold and we'll
put a link to it in our show notes
this has been grit and growth from the
Stanford Graduate School of Business I'm
your host Darius Teeter
if you like this episode follow us and
leave a review on your favorite podcast
app Erica amoakaya Jay and VN virgin
researched and developed content for
this episode Kendra gladich is our
production coordinator and our executive
producer is Tiffany Steves with writing
and production from Andrew Gannon and
sound design and mixing by Alex Bennett
at lower Street Media thanks for joining
us we'll be back soon with another
episode
[Music]